hello I'm a nostalgia credit guy
remember it so you don't have to believe
it or not there was an age when Michael
Jackson was a god his songs were Smash
Hits his dancing was beyond compare and
women fainted at just the sight of him
rather than fainting at just the sight
so at the top of his reign Michael
Jackson released his cinematic opus moon
water a strange little ego trip that
shows us that not only does Jackson know
how to sing and dance but actually
that's it sing and dance because clearly
he doesn't know how to tell a story keep
focus or pull us in by any emotional
meet instead we get sort of a photo
album of his table scraps that mostly
looks like scenes that would have been
edited out of much better music videos
what do I mean by all of this well let's
venture into this little amusement park
of awkwardness to find out first off why
is it called moon Walker anyway I mean
yeah he does the dance move a few times
but there's no real focus on it you
could have just as easily called a
crotch grab and it would have made just
as much sense so we see the world's
first Universal answer to every joke
ever written Michael Jackson we've kept
him at that stage where he wasn't really
a good-looking black man anymore but at
least he was a halfway decent looking
white we see him performing at a concert
singing about how we can all change the
world and apparently all of the world
leaders by Jackson's plea for world
peace I am in thought up at the Michael
Jackson
each bin I'm Michael Jackson
you know Michael Jackson made this all
possible
ah have a dream to support Michael
Jackson's dream pinkie cheese I believe
you can change your plastic surgery
operations and clearly shown that so
okay we get a bit of him performing know
what oh we see pictures of him
performing all right
okay so we've seen pictures of him
performing now what oh we get freakish
animations of him performing that that's
nice and they turn into the California
Raisins for some reason Lincoln the
Michael Jackson performances some we
turn to the monkey Python cartoons
Michael Jackson signs so okay we get
animations of him performing I must ask
again what's next oh we get a montage of
him performing Wow he's just so humble
about his faith it's like he doesn't
even know that he's famous Oh Michael
please don't be so modest indulge
yourself a bit I don't think the image
of you as a shiny golden Messiah is
strong enough don't you have any oceans
of water to walk on or dead people to
resurrect ie come on George a little
especially like this picture of him and
et which is almost looking like a before
and after picture
yes we get it Michael Jackson is awesome
please shut up yes raping the at-fault
is cool now if you did it it must be
cool please contribute something more
other than your ego I've just shown you
how secure I am a little too confident
because that's what they call me they
call me baby secure if they have to name
an airport after me they were caught
Michaels secure Jackson Airport that's
what they call me in fact that's what
they call me right now Michael secure
Jackson Airport there wait shit just
love how to carry on I'm so secure very
big very secure kill me so and I'm not
kidding here after 20 minutes of just
watching his self-indulgent clips we
finally get some new material no please
I think there was a pensee commercial
you might have missed so we jump to a
strange recut of his famous bad music
video except this time is done with
little children instead of adults
I guess this is supposed to be charming
but I don't know this seems kind of like
the male equivalent of the Little Miss
pageants it's more creepy that is
endearing
there's even to see where the kid
accidentally grabs his balls too hard
why don't you even make that joke that's
like a joke I would make except when I
make it it's funny when you make it it's
unnaturally disturbing Oh bad who's bad
I'll tell you who's bad little kids wear
hair gel and dance around like a dope
ballerinas that bad motherfucker
so they exit the scene trying to have
some normal conversation but that comes
off as a little abnormal the ball was in
my trailer yes sir
where's he wearing he's Reina Prince
t-shirt and red sneakers yeah he just
asked what a monkey was wearing so we
see them leave the studio as a cloud of
smoke for some reason transforms them
into adults because she acts and wins it
I guess
we then see a tour bus filled with what
looks like Davey and Goliath satanic
replacements and believe it or not this
is where it gets strange Jackson is
chased by a bunch of stop-motion fans
including the noise I don't know Jackson
wills it as he interrupts a Western
being shot by an impatient director who
also seems to be animated in stop-motion
I'm sorry my producer is doing this to
me isn't he
I asked for a bad guy and he gives me
Michael yeah boy George Lucas was
high-strung in his early years so they
chase him into a makeup trailer where
Jackson finds the perfect disguise to
sneak out of the Easter Bunny version of
Joe Camel of course
me what's up douche of course the clay
puppets fall for the trick is nobody
seems to see past the disguise Kenny
what behind the rabbit is that so we see
this musical chase scene as all the
stop-motion characters ride after
Michael but Michael pulls them by
shape-shifting into several different
characters like a construction worker
tina turner and even pee-wee Herman this
is crack you know they really should
called this mind fucker as opposed to
moon Walker that would have been more
accurate so he looses gumbies
gang-bangers as he decides to finally
take off the costume but it turns out
the costume wants to dance sure why not
now yes I forgot this was a guy who make
crotch-grabbing outside the house
popular but a cop notifies him that
there's no Michael Jackson again these
parts and is forced to write a ticket
it's because I'm black isn't it your
block and just before he leaves the face
of his bunny pal appears to say farewell
why why you're really gonna bother to
ask why in this movie we've been cut to
the next segment which is probably the
funniest in my opinion it's another
strange music video with all sorts of
surreal images but the name of the song
is entitled leave me alone are you
serious you just spent the first half of
this movie pleading for attention
begging people to look at you and
acknowledge you as some sort of musical
God and now you're suddenly telling
people to leave you alone what did the
aliens do to your brain anyway I guess
this is a response to all the newspaper
tabloids that were written about it at
the time I especially like it when he
constantly sings the line I don't care
what you think
that's right I don't care what you think
at this incredibly expensive musical
representation of a middle finger
clearly shows Michael we would love to
leave you alone but you just make it so
constantly difficult that is pretty much
impossible it's like a train wreck that
you're told to ignore it's simply not
gonna happen so we cut to probably the
most famous part of the movie you know
the portion that has the whole
Spielberg's and make a slight feel to it
and I have to say this is easily the
best part of the movie because it starts
off with Michael Jackson's best scene
people trying to kill it we want to
throw you my brain by Catherine II up
but boy howdy how did all this insanity
start well one of Michael's many
children friends cut into a flashback to
show us how this all began this takes
place in the salad days when Michael was
allowed to be around children the hills
are alive with the sound of Jamal you
see Michael playing in the hills of
perfect Tokyo when their dog suddenly
wanders off into the forest so Michael
and one of the kids go searching for him
and then it goes Raiders of the Lost Ark
Adams for some reason as Michael
stumbles onto a secret bad location seal
nobody's come out of that alive it turns
out they've come across an evil gang of
drug dealers because yeah all drug
dealers do their evil plotting in the
middle of the fucking forest don't they
every kid in the school worth to take
drugs because of me because of me or
everybody to know everybody my name is
gonna be in history books they better
spell my name like that poor peacock
with leukemia is actually Joe Pesci
playing the sinister role of
mileage-based Joe Pesci his evil plans
to get all the little children in the
world completely high on drugs why
because there's nothing else Joe Pesci
can do on a Saturday night I guess
but the cover is blown as Jackson and
the girl just barely escaped but as we
see the evil drunk thugs caught up with
them as they try to hunt him down and
kill him before he reveals their evil
plans but Jackson escapes as he runs
down the alleyway while Pesci screams
like a Scottish terrier Michael on which
Pesci by running yeah he does a lot of
that in this scene so he continues to
run and then after that he runs some
more but then he throws him for a
surprising blue by giving them oh god
damn it he's just running it yeah he
says Christ he's just running back and
forth between the same two locations how
is this exciting
and then because you loved it so much at
normal speed we have running in slow
motion how breathtaking please keep your
crotch at least 30 feet away from us
that's a restraining order from the
world listen to him he's beating
Yosemite Sam oh did I say your dog
blasted ornery balnaird
varmint but Michaels in luck because he
comes across a shooting star and as you
all know when you wish upon a star you
turn into a fucking transformer
the chance Rock
yeah Michaels a car now surprised we
didn't see the kids he was playing with
earlier
don't read too deep into that as they
meet the rendezvous point where Jackson
said he would come so michael enters
into the nightclub that was once empty
but is now magically full as he partakes
in ah the coolest fucking thing I've
ever seen in my life I'm serious I have
no problems with this music video
portion called smooth crimnal me this is
about as close to perfection as a music
video can get I mean god this is
unbelievable
why is he suddenly singing what is he
even doing there suddenly none of that
really matters
we are just sunken into the kick-ass
amounts of awesomeness this whole scene
displays the design the style the dance
ends of music I can't find a single flaw
with this entire Seas well if you want
me to nip it I guess there are few
things like just what the hell is he
saying anyway
there's also a weird scene where he
shoots a guy trying to stab them and
then somehow email through the wall but
probably the strangest seems come right
dab in the middle when the music stops
and everything goes strangely quiet the
people start rubbing each other so I'm
gonna start screaming Michael turns into
a bobblehead and it just keeps going
it's like they're at an orgy but they
forgot the sex okay
we apologize for that ladies and
gentlemen just a slight mental breakdown
there
we now return you to your kick-ass
entertainer well just like that weirdest
smooth criminal is one of the greatest
musical numbers of all time I'm sure I'm
gonna get a lot of negative points for
saying this but to me this is better and
don't get me wrong I love thriller it's
a friggin masterpiece but really
revolutionize the music video smooth
criminal' perfecting it look at style
look at the staging with the dancing the
entire scope of this music video is just
cute there's never been another music
video like it and don't even get me
started on that Alien Ant fuck version
how they actually thought they could do
a legit send up to this song is just
ridiculous yeah just keep bopping your
heads up and down I'm gonna watch the
actual adults here
Oh No the plot please go away we were
having a good time
I could play that clip against some of
the other scenes we saw earlier go to
the woods over here well it's about as
consistent as anything else in this
movie so just as we saw the most epic of
musical sequences the story comes back
to ruin the show we found out that the
girls been kidnapped and it's up to the
King of Pop of course to go and save her
he goes back to the hideout as he's
surrounded by henchmen who start kicking
the crap out of him and make him watch
as the evil cockatoo starts feeding the
little girl but apparently Michael has
some supernatural friends to help him
out the destructive traveler asked
it's just as I thought Michael Jackson
is an alien robot this all suddenly
makes sense I guess I say more confusing
so without any explanation why he turned
into a machine Michael Jackson becomes
pop Thomas prime as you start blowing
the shit out of all the evildoers he can
find I just want to bring love and
chilli we'll just watch him as he goes
GI Joe on their assets
so after all the henchmen disappear
Michael Jackson transformed into a giant
okay I have no idea what's going on here
I'm just enjoying the pretty images
are you you kiddin what drug dealer has
a Marvin the Martian laser gun let's see
just dealing coke for the Acme
corporation or something you're ignorant
so Pesci zeroes in to kill the rest of
our little heroes until so Michael runs
out of things to blow up and decides
it's time to call it an action filled
day why
goodbye
thank you local why is he leaving what
do the kids know that we don't know it's
like hey here's some random cliches we
won't bother to tell you together with a
story we just figure that slow things
down goodbye kids I hope you can catch a
ride home truly this man was the King of
Pop so the kids sit and mope as they
reminisce about what a fearless godchild
Michael was a manga style remember
Michael with his lucky star it's okay
kid on the third day He will rise again
and absolve us of our sins but it turns
out Michael returns okay no explanation
or anything he just returned I guess he
couldn't stay out of the movie for more
than two seconds and not only that he
has something very special he wants to
show them but he has to take him to a
big dark empty basement where they have
to be very very quiet ah no it's just a
concert oh yay we started out with an
ego boosting show and now we add with an
ego boosting show how charming well at
least I'm sure but kids will enjoy it
right I don't know we never see them
again the last thing we see of them is
them getting reunited with their stupid
dog we don't even know if they made it
to the concert or ether even watching
Michaels ego just seemed to disintegrate
them from the story altogether
what an absolutely charming waist so how
does Michael Jackson's little
psychological arthouse film hold up well
I can sum it up like this crab crab crab
crab crab crack holy mother of god that
is so freakin cool cramp why couldn't
this film just be a music video that's
what pretty much was to begin with a
bunch of music videos it would have been
stronger and more memorable instead we
have to sit through this annoying vacuum
of attention just so we can get to the
good part or in this case just one good
part Michael you're incredible I mean
then three different ways incredibly
talented incredibly gifted and
incredibly scary just stick to what you
know best and we'll watch you but please
the whole storytelling element to the
prose okay then tell the stories and you
can go back to looking like
about Carter from Planet of the Apes and
I never look at myself in the mirror
ever start I'm a Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to